then he go real fast
hey friends it's caramel from netflix's
queer eye and i'm his son jason brown
also known as rachel's sideburns and
today we are cooking a traditional
jamaican dish called aki and sawfish
with a side of bummi it's a chameleon
dish tommy raita nice so what i love
about afghan style fish is that it
reminds me of home so i just remember my
grandmother and my grandfather cooking
akienzo fish on sunday mornings and then
cutting up the bamy and just like all of
the family coming together and i was
just eating traditional jamaican dishes
i mean in my household my father
actually used cooking as a way to bond
with me and it's also a way that i used
to bond with my son i'll be honest early
on we were very much hands on when the
kitchen
my dad used to embed in my head that i
need to know how to cook as a man so
tell me how to cook chicken rice
spaghetti pasta all the like all the
things
i'm just saying all right men cook women
cook everyone should be cooking it's a
great way to talk try new things to be
curious about life and that's what i
love about food
all right so the thing about jason and i
is that when you cook sometimes you
gotta take a little dance break it
starts with the hands you gotta come in
you gotta come here
all right now back to cooking
so right now the bami looks really plain
and that's why we're going to be adding
in coconut milk which gives it a really
robust sweet flavor that just is so
you can't wait to bite into it it
actually balances out the all the rich
flavors of the acne and the vegetables
so you know for me pride month is a very
important special month because it's
where i started to find the confidence
in myself as a gay man and then as i had
a son it was really important for him to
understand that it was great for you to
be a part of the community to see the
strength and the beauty of the lgbtqia
community because i think a lot of times
parents are afraid to introduce their
children to their community their
surroundings but i think it helps them
to grow and be better for me pride
definitely is one of the best times i've
ever possibly had in the summer time you
know we live it up we honestly have a
good time and we celebrate the pride
that we all have for the community so
this is where you start to break up the
salt fish but you know what real cooks
we use our hands get rid of the forks
just get your hands in there that's what
real cooks do just start grinding it up
you start to feel the texture of the
fish you start to feel like you're
infused with the food and this is my
favorite part actually when we're
stirring in the red peppers the green
peppers the onions the aki everything
looks so beautiful right now see this is
the part about jamaican dishes that i
love is that they incorporate so many
fresh vegetables that you get to see the
color and it smells so fragrant i mean
just whisk that in son whip it in you
smell it right smells good i know so
jason and i have a brand new book coming
out called i am perfectly designed this
book is a children's book it's a picture
book but it's also for adults because as
we know whether you're 2 20 or 220
i don't know anybody that age without
trying to figure out how to go in
sequence we all have issues with our
self-esteem where we're like i don't
feel good about myself today i feel like
someone's better than me or you start
comparing yourself and this book is to
teach all of us and remind all of us
that we are perfectly designed basically
it just always taught me to be myself
you know and that's kind of the main
point of this whole book is for
everybody to know that themselves
naturally is perfect we have everything
we need friends to create the life we
want you just gotta believe in yourself
it's all on you
you ready to try the dish i am so ready
so are you you just went straight in for
it okay yeah it's so delicious you have
no idea
you can taste every bit of the acne you
can take the sawfish salt fish if you're
an american this office if you're
jamaican as my son continues to eat i
just want to remind everyone to check
out our brand new book i am perfectly
designed coming out in the fall and also
i want to encourage everyone to try
different foods from different cultures
be curious there's so many things out
there that you're just going to love to
try but you got to be curious enough to
go after it start with this dish start
with something new during pride month
trust me you will not be disappointed
happy pride friends good pride oh yes
[Music]
you